Nước lúc của cho nhiều tổ giữa được phố tình hả vắc sau khoảng lưu báo báo báo vi.
Báo báo vi đồ bộ báo đất liền Trung Quốc tối mì một tháng bài.
Sau gần hai ngày, báo suy yếu nhưng khoảng lưu báo gắn gây gió mạnh và mưa lớn tại nhiều tình được bắt Trung Quốc,
gồm liêu ninh hả vắc, ăn vi, rằng tầy và chết rằng.
Theo tên hoa sá, hơn 2,5 người tại tính chết rằng đã được sử tán.
Thành phố thượng 2 đã sử tán hơn 2,5 chi Minh hành người khỏi các khu vực viêm.
Tình phúc kiến sử tán hơn 1,5 tám mình hành người.
Tại liều ninh, mối báo thành phố đã kích hoạt biệt pháp ứng phó khẩn cấp trong lũ, hơn 1,5 người đã được sơ tán.
Thành phố thượng bán hành kành báo lũ đò, mước ứng phó khẩn cấp phóng trong lũ cũng được nâng lên mức cảm nhận.
Cơ quan khi tượng dự báo thượng dương sẽ tục có mưa từ sống người đến 1 chăm sóng người bị li đến hết nè người 1 tháng bài.
Báo báo vi đi qua phía bắc này loàn ngày 1 tháng bài, khiến ít nhất 1 chăm bà mì từ người bị thương, theo dự hòa này loàn.
Tại phía lis, mưa lớn sau báo ngày 1 lợ và ngập lụn làm khi tết mệt tả người thêm mạng, mời hành người mất tích.